il une rép que vousz
àis tpects question
suiv pourquoi la motivationz deou tu
notre franis devant
cam
berandig
répond
sec fois je sors dans la rue avec mon
pistolet dans la poche comme ça je
marche et je me dis que le premier qui
me chercherait je le CRA portant déjà
moi je trouve que c'est un exploit assez
formidable avec un film sur la violence
de faire une sorte de réconciliation
nationale peu commune puisque le journal
le plus SN de France libération et le
journal le plus populaire de France Le
Figaro se trouve réuni dans la même idée
cela dit ça me paraît assez absurde je
veux dire on bon au départ le prix du
danger
c'est un grand film d'action extrêmement
spectaculaire sur qui débouche sur une
réflexion sur la violence et sur
l'utilisation des médias en particulier
de la télévision bon mais on reproche
pas à Mad Max par exemple qui lui ne se
pose aucun problème sur la violence de
ne pas dénoncer la violence al au
contraire le prix du danger est en même
temps une sorte d'avertissement sur ce
que pourrait devenir la
télévision si on nétait pas très
vigilant et si on faisait pas attention
à la façon dont s exploité certains jeux
télévisés aux États-Unis ou en Allemagne
par exemple François Jacquemard atteint
une côte de popularité bien supérieure à
tout ce qu'on pouvait espérer dirais
même qu'aucune Venette de music ou de
cinéma aucun homme politique aucune
célébrité n'a jamais été aussi haut 17,9
mais c le record absolu c'est fabuleux
c'est un homme qui exerce une telle
fascination sur les gens mais ça n'a pas
de prix qu'est-ce que vous voulaz dire
par là préciser elle veut dire qu'avoir
fabriqué une telle vedette pour la tuer
aussi vite c'est un peu ABS s vous
trouvez pas mais Laurence a raison les
autres étaient abattus comme prévu à la
fin de l'émission mais Jacques Mar une
telle notoriété un tel impact c'est vrai
ça il sera peut-être plus avantageux de
le laisser gagner on lui fait un contrat
et nos annonceur la chpridor et dans le
contexte dans lequel il évoluit je me
suis dit que finalement aujourd'hui on
avait une possibilité de trouver ce
genre d'individu dans la rue tout
simplement un type qui s'ennuie qui a
plus rien qui a plus d'espoir plus de
rêve et à qui on propose un million de
dollars donc radicalement changer toute
sa vie dire que par les temps qui court
on devrait pouvoir trouver des candidats
au Prix du danger assez fréquemment
maintenant et je me suis dit qu'à partir
du moment où j'y croyait à ce personnage
c'estàdire qu'il était possible de le
rencontrer il a été facile en tout cas
de s'y introduire à l'intérieur et et de
et de d'y trouver toutes les motivations
pour le jouer vous pensez que pour de
l'argent les G sont capables de faire
n'importe quoi pour de l'argent les gens
sont capables de faire n'importe quoi
mais c'est
évident